tu gagnes et 800 euros par mois grâce à
son don est arrivé voilà à t'en sortir
et là avec la crise c'est catastrophique
pour toi exactement
j'aimerais rebondi en fait c'est ce que
madame la ministre a dit tout à l'heure
en fait on a à peu près la même histoire
c'est que bon ici également j'ai perdu
mes deux par à bas le dernier en 2018
qui était mon père eh ben il a fallu bas
que je mûris dynamisant fait beaucoup de
passes aubry en fait dans la dépression
et du coup bas à continuer mes études
et ben je suis on va dit passionné de
journalisme mais j'ai pas voulu faire ça
en fait parce que j'ai toujours voulu
défendre des causes des gens et du coup
bah je me suis orientée hors droits
malheureusement j'ai décidé de prendre
notre part coup c'est à dire après mon
master 1 droit des affaires j'ai décidé
de montrer ali a eu pour faire on fait
de la conformité et du contrôle interne
des risques en fait tu vois travailler
dans les métiers de la banque
vu qu'aujourd'hui avec la lutte anti
blanchiment financement du terrorisme
qui est beaucoup en fait d'actualité
avec les sanctions que mais la cépière
du coup bah c'est des choses qui
m'incite plus et des choses on va dire
qu'ils me donnent envie de découvrir
mais le problème le réel problème c'est
que d'abord pour trouver une alternance
est déjà difficile parce que moi en fait
je me suis donné un motif de devoir en
fait faire postuler 20 cv par jour
quand vous multipliez les 20 cm x la
semaine et que vous me tue plus haut moi
ça fait 400 cv et recevoir juste un seul
d'entre eux a envoyé 400 c bat simard
bah là ça m'a fait ça fait dix-huit
mille cd par an à peu près bas la save a
fait 800 ha et de bonnes photocopieuse a
fait 800 cv j'ai eu un seul entretien et
que l'entretien se passe bien selon moi
parce que bah on a serré senti et
qu'elle a fait en fait la personne au
bout du fil me dis bah j'ai senti que
bah vous n'allez pas être épanoui dans
l'entreprise
je trouve que là c'est inadmissible en
france parce que bah je suis d'accord
qu'on peut te refuse on peut refuser
époux m motifs mehdi en fait bas j'ai
senti c'est à 10 m en fait l'émotion
avant en fait les critères là par contre
je trouve que bas dans un pays comme la
france c'est inacceptable et du coup bah
moi en fait ce soir je suis venu
témoigner en fait de ça mais aussi
inciter office aussi les politiques ça a
su panchir
également su tu les besoins des
étudiants parce que je sais que sur le
plateau il ya une étude ya des études
qui sont en droit et que bah quand on
regarde le cursus d'un étudiant normal
endroit et que baho sortie des études de
droit qu'on a six mois on a 6 mois
d'expérience mais on ne peut pas se
vendre sur le marché de l'emploi qu'on
l'ait des cabinets d'avocats où tu
déposes de dcv tu as déjà prise mais qui
te fait mme laporte parce que juste tu
n'as pas le diplôme ou richard chez ba
le diplôme ou femme en te demandant plus
que l'anglais alors qu'on en france il
que j'ai pas dis j'ai battu ne
compterait que longuet n'est pas
important mais ça n'a pas été un critère
de deux ans vingt dix discriminateur
parce que on comprend on peut pas tous
comprendre l'anglais mais au moins on
peut être opérationnels mais eux quand
ils te disent ils te demandent 5 ans
d'expérience il te demande
l'anglais sur lui écrit il veut le haut
niveau a pas d'homme je pense que là en
fait il ya un problème il dirait que ça
elisabeth ya beaucoup de gens qui le
disaient sur les réseaux il ya beaucoup
trop de de teddy être beaucoup trop de
choses qui sont demandés comment quand
vous voulez qu'il y arrive ça qu'est ce
que vous répondez à salamine alors
qu'effectivement on sait très bien que
c'est plus compliqué pour les jeunes de
trouver un emploi c'est bien pour ça
qu'on a fait le plan un jeune une
solution parce qu'on est conscient qu'on
a demandé beaucoup de sacrifices aux
jeunes pendant la crise sanitaire avec
toutes les règles qui se sont appliqués
et on sait que les jeunes sont
systématiquement les plus touchés moi
j'aimerais vous étiez déconner je vais
pas vous couper la parole mais mais un
plug le fait quand même
l'emploi pour moi en fait il ya eu il
peut avoir des avantages ne dis pas le
contraire mais moi en fait j'ai trouvé
que dalle su ça est-ce que je m'en
doutais mais j'ai retrouvé que dalle su
su cette plateforme ces maquis on a mis
en caisse qu'on vient chercher
qu'est ce que vous cherchez je cherche
mon goût je cherche une alternance parce
que pour moi offert pour faire au fait
de la conformité
parce que pour moi c'est une alternance
c'est avoir un an d'expérience et mieux
le vent tu le marché de l'emploi mais je
vais si je peux pas je peux pas avoir ni
de l'alternance ni un stage je trouve
que bah en fait un beau diable c'est
assez rare et on veut une alternance
dans quels domaines dans le domaine de
la conformité
ce que ce soit en banque ou une
entreprise à dans la conformité
oui une conformité ou deux selon moi
j'avais alors je vais te dire projet de
présenter quelqu'un mais bon c'est pas
du tout là dedans coin là là je sui 1
bat là je suis à côté de la plaque on va
quand même recevoir recevoir barbares en
grève sauvage ilana market avec ping
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci merci d'al ahmar qui est venu avec
sa famille apparemment dans le public
merci la nama vous êtes fondateur et
directeur général de eleven paris
c'est une marque de vêtements on aime
beaucoup voilà un nom mais c'est vrai
c'est nouveau c'est très beau pas
possible je vous aime beaucoup pour va
se faire des compliments c'est une
marque de vêtements de mode qui a été
créée en 2003 et comme il a vu pour
travailler avant chez sandro donc on
s'est dit on voulait vous proposer
quelque chose c'est ça on n'est pas dans
la conformité clairement pas fait c'est
vrai mais en tout cas voilà on sait que
vous êtes sur lyon on sait que
aujourd'hui enfin vous avez travaillé
déjà dans le prêt-à-porter
on a une boutique sur lyon est là le
besoin se faisait aider que l'émission
nous a contactés on s'est vraiment dit
si on peut aider
c'est le moment de faire personnellement
je sais que c'est assez compliqué parce
que je vois beaucoup de jeunes qui nous
contactent aujourd'hui nature qui sont
en galère clairement utilisé ce terme le
plus con ce qu'on remarque nous
aujourd'hui c'est que je pense qu'il ya
une perte au niveau des codes
c'est à dire qu'à l'époque on savait
avant le coc vide on fait des études qui
sont vous avez compliqué donc le fait
d'avoir à côté un loyer à payer parfois
on a quitté la province parfois on est à
paris parfois c'est cher parfois c'est
compliqué donc c'est assez complexe
d'avoir à gérer ça après le co lead et
on s'est rendu compte aujourd'hui qu'à
plein de nouvelles façons de nous
aborder et on embauche des personnes qui
nous abordent de manière complètement
folle déjà les réseaux sociaux en nous
envoyant des vidéos en essayant de créer
des nouvelles façons de nous approcher
et c'est vrai que tout ce qui se faisait
par le cv à l'époque aujourd'hui c'est
en tout cas moi puisque je suis d'une
nouvelle génération
c'est de moins en moins efficace parce
qu'on fait confiance souvent en réseau
hta pas le bon 0,6 comme on disait
et c'est vrai que voilà aujourd'hui
c'est pas le cv qui nous a fait dire ça
ce que j'ai écouté ça m'a fait chaud au
coeur
donc j'espère que matisse et pas de la
conformité on vas pouvoir te proposer
quelque chose assez rapidement parce
qu'on voulait de mettre à l'essai en
boutique
voilà et que tu puisse travailler un
petit peu avec nous parce que cet
intérêt sur julien bas pour être honnête
envers vous moi symplus je suis plus je
veux travailler en entreprise en fait je
si j'ai décidé de
abandonnée en fait ça alors vous êtes
alors il ya thibault je crois quelque
chose à proposer t'inquiète pas on n'est
pas venu les mains vides à vous je peux
vous envoyer ma mère sur l'île c'est
important c'est pour l'argent
bah oui à la thibault même chose que ça
sera important quand même d'avoir un
montant qui accompagne bien sûr liquide
écouter puis qui fait en sortir mais
aussi parce que c'est un chef
d'entreprise
mine de rien il va il va être ton mentor
et je pense que c'est important aussi
que tu es quelqu'un a pu parler à qui tu
peux exposer aussi des problèmes quand
même dit thibault et c'est vrai que ilan
c'est quelqu'un voilà c'est un chef
d'entreprise qui pourra être écoutée
elle est tombée encore est-ce que ça ça
t'intéresse pas combien rs ménagers
contact mais on met en jeu williams est
alors évidemment que sur la plateforme
c'est pas miraculeux bon il ya quand
même un peu plus de deux cent mille
offres d'emploi il ya vingt mille offres
de stages
t'as pas trouvé chaussure à tes pieds
sur sur la plateforme mais du coup j'ai
passé quelques coups de téléphone parce
que je j'ai déjà accompagné quelques
étudiants qui tu es dans ton cas il
c'est vrai que pour le droit pour
pouvoir réussir c'est très compliqué de
trouver des stages c'est vrai c'est et
on à l'entreprise vicat qui est une
entreprise qui est qui s'est engagée de
la première heure dans un jeune une
solution qui est un des leaders dans le
comment dire dans le ciment et qui dans
le lyonnais enfin à côté de lyon et qui
est prêt à t'accueillir en contrat
d'apprentissage
pourquoi tu puisse poursuivre ses études
et qui est prêt à embaucher
enfin il faut que tu ailles les voir
évidemment mais on s'intéresse à rien
bah oui quand même je pense que
peut-être qui est important en fait dans
ce que dit thibault c'est que c'est pas
le plan du gouvernement un jeune une
solution il faut que tout le monde se
mobilise sur fait avec votre émission
et puis les entreprises on s'adresse
aussi aux entreprises y en a huit qui se
sont engagés pour les jeunes qui
comprennent que la crise c'est un moment
qui est difficile pour tout le monde et
spécialement pour les jeunes et qu'il
faut qu'elle fasse un effort donc elle
les aides que le gouvernement met en
place
8000 euros quand on embauche un jeune en
contrat d'apprentissage donc ça peut
quand même les aider mais il faut aussi
qu'elle y met du sien et c'est tout le
sens du travail qui est fait notamment
je vais vous dire pour que les
entreprises s'engagent